- [Narrator] In this video,
we're going to cover what
criteria a non citizen must meet
to become a citizen.
A process we call naturalization.
Some of the requirements
are obvious and verifiable
while others are tested through
the naturalization process.
There are nine requirements
that an immigrant must meet
before they can apply for naturalization.
And four of the first five all have to do
with how long an applicant has
lived in the United States.
First, they have to be 18 years old.
Does this mean that children
can't become citizens?
No, but they can't apply on their own.
If their parent or parents
apply for naturalization,
a child can inherit their
parent's citizenship
if they make it through the process.
Second, the applicant has to
have been a permanent resident
for at least five years,
unless they're married
to an American citizen
then it's only three years.
So this means that undocumented immigrants
and foreign diplomats
are not eligible for naturalization.
Third, they have to
show that they've lived
in the US customs
and immigration services
district they've been living in
when they applied for
at least three months.
There are 26 US CIS districts
which also include US territories.
Fourth, they have to have lived
in the United States continuously
for at least five years.
A green card holder can leave
for short periods of time,
but if they've lived
outside the United States
for more than six months,
they could compromise their
eligibility for naturalization.
Included in that is the fifth requirement
that they have to have
been physically present
in the United States
for at least 30 months
out of the five years
of residency they maintained
before they file their
application for naturalization.
These five cover the
residency requirements
for naturalization, but there
are four other requirements
that are verified during the
naturalization process itself.
If you remember the steps of
the naturalization process,
you should remember that at one point,
a person seeking
naturalization needs to meet
with a US CIS official for an interview.
and to take the naturalization test.
It's during this step
that the US CIS official
tests the applicant
on the next two requirements,
their ability to understand English
and their knowledge of US
history and government.
The federal government requires
that all naturalized citizens
can read, write, speak
and understand conversational English.
The interview itself serves as the test
for the speaking portion.
And after the interview, the
applicant has to read one
out of three chosen sentences correctly.
And for the writing test,
the applicant will write an
English sentence provided
by the interviewer.
Following the English portion,
the interviewer asks 10 questions
about US history and government
and the applicant must answer
at least six correctly.
Some examples of questions that
an interviewer can ask are,
how many amendments does
the constitution have?
Or, who's in charge of
the executive branch?
Then there are only two requirements left,
and they're the hardest to verify
because they aren't entirely obvious.
The eighth requirement for
naturalization is that you have
to be a person of good moral character.
Trying to determine a person's
character is hard to do.
Do you think you could get a good grasp
of a person's character in an interview
that lasts a few hours
or reading an application they filled out?
The way the government
determines moral character
is by looking to see if an
applicant has a criminal history,
but that isn't exactly foolproof.
They can look into American
criminal databases,
but they don't have access
to other countries' criminal records.
US CIS often has to
rely on self reporting.
And while it is rare for
someone with a criminal history
to make it through the
naturalization process,
it has been known to happen.
The final requirement
is that the applicant has
to demonstrate an attachment
to the principles and ideals
of the US Constitution.
This means that an applicant has to prove
that they would actively
support the constitution
and support a democratic
form of government.
If someone is hostile to
the form of government
in the United States, they
cannot become a citizen.
One way that a person proves this
is by agreeing to take
an oath of allegiance
in a public ceremony.
In this oath,
they must promise to renounce
all foreign allegiance,
though that does not mean they have
to give up their citizenship
to other countries and promise
to give full allegiance
to the United States, its
constitution and its laws.
They must also promise to perform
all duties and obligations
of citizenship including
defending the country
when called upon.
So now that we've covered
all of the requirements,
let's go through an example
to see if you can determine
whether an immigrant
is eligible for citizenship or not.
Lorenzo has lived most
of his life in Italy,
but now he wants to become a US citizen.
He came to the United
States three years ago
and has been a legal resident ever since.
He has never been in trouble with the law,
either in the United States or in Italy.
He enjoys owning his own home
and living in a friendly neighborhood.
Lorenzo is 25 years old,
speaks English very well and
has recently taken a class
at a local community college on US history
for new citizens.
He filled out his naturalization
application form last week.
So let's check off all of the requirements
that Lorenzo does have.
Take a second and pause this video
to try and figure it
out on your own first.
All right, so Lorenzo is 25 years old
so he meets the minimum age requirement.
He's only been a permanent
resident for three years
and he's not married to a US citizen
so he doesn't meet the
residency requirement.
He's lived in Portland for three years
so he meets the third
and fifth requirements,
but he doesn't meet
the fourth requirement.
Lorenzo can speak English very well
and took a class on US
history for new immigrants
so we can assume that he
can pass both portions
of the naturalization test.
And since he's never been
in any legal trouble,
we'll put a check mark next
to him having good moral character.
We can't exactly tell if he's
attached to the principles
and ideals of the US Constitution
so we'll put a question mark
next to that requirement.
All right, given all this information,
do you think Lorenzo is eligible
to apply for naturalization?
If you answered no, you're correct.
Even though Lorenzo meets
a lot of the requirements,
he doesn't meet all of
them and eligibility
is an all or nothing type deal.
He has to meet all nine
requirements before he can apply.
In the next video, we'll
cover some of the challenges
of the naturalization process.